It's part of a sense of being dutiful and having no problem, actually,
with being dutiful in a marriage.
Yes, I believe that traditionalism can.
It is putting your family before yourself. And I think it is.
It is having those traditional values that were once
definitely more in place. And god,
family and love. And we live in a very selfish society now,
you know, you see self love printed everywhere.
Right. And, um, women.
I'm speaking of divorce and marriage.
Women are leaving marriage far more easy,
easier than men. And they are, um,
doing it
because they think there's something better out there for them,
that the grass is greener on the other side.
And they're finding out that is wrong,
and they're going through divorce after divorce. And, um.
You know, marriage is a bond,
and it's a sacred bond where two become one under god.
And that's beautiful. And you have to protect that at all costs.
And I think part of that is
putting your partner's needs before your own
every single day. And I try and do my best.
And I think of my husband as much as I can
and what will please him and make him happy.
I love the sound of this. Sorry,
I mean. I mean,
obviously I don't. I wouldn't dare to express